How was your journey?
It was terrible. I got the bus because I'm
poor and it smelt like warm, raw chicken and
I'm really nervous, so I thought I was going
to shit myself the whole way in, but I
didn't. And if I'm sitting weirdly, it's
because I think my tampons come out. But I
didn't have time to go to the bathroom
downstairs because I slept in, because I
spent so long last night trying to make
myself come. But I couldn't because of my
anti-depressants.
I don't know why I just told you that.
It's my thing.
I know what would cheer you up.
I'm not sad.
Oh, God, not you again.
Oh, hey, Hitler. Suck a dick. Everyone's cool
with interracial marriage.
Yeah, you're inside my white girlfriend, and we
fuck at least twice a month.
Oh, who am I? Let's invade Russia in the
winter because I'm a big, dumb bitch.
Ha ha ha. Very funny.
Oh, the Jews are broadly doing okay.
La la la la la la la la. I'm not listening.
Can you hear that?
The ominous music?
Yeah.
I keep telling reception to warn people before they come in.
It's my power.
I make people generate their own soundtrack
around me. I'm going to assume you're afraid
of the dentist.
No.
Shall we get started?
Right. Let's take a look.
Well, the good news is you have quite nice teeth.
No, no, wait, wait, wait, wait.
The bad news is we're going to have to do
quite a few fillings today.
Right. I can't listen to this.
What'd you think? Full show?
[screams]
What the fuck?
I'm not a man. I'm a cat.
No, no, no. I'm a man, not a cat. I'm a man.
Oh, my God. You can see me. You can see me.
Please help me. Please. It's okay.
Ow.
Oh. Oh.
What's going on? We heard screaming.
I've got my power.
I've got magic tits.
Oh.
Cat sees my tits.
Cat turns into man. My tits turn cats into men.
It's pretty straightforward.
Can you stop thinking about your mission for two seconds, please.
But this is important. I can have sex with you anytime.
No! Don't you dare.
Can you stop thinking about your mission for two seconds, please.
Of course.
You know you're the most important thing to me.